hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled innovative approaches to
biomarker discovery in the drug
development process
this webinar is a part of the drug
discovery and development 2022 event
i am liz pitts of nanostring and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
nanastring
for more information about nanostring
including our spatial biology platform
being featured here today
please go to nanostring.com
now let's get started
before we begin i'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to first participate by
communicating with other attendees using
the new live chat feature during the
presentation
you can find the live chat located at
the right of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you would like
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you do have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation you can click on the
help desk button located at the bottom
of your screen within the navigation bar
or from the lobby
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits link located in the abstract
window below the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
and now
i'm going to present today's speaker dr
esperanza
anguiano scientific market development
director of biopharma at nanastring
technologies
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen and with that dr
angriano you may now begin your
presentation
thank you nice for the introduction and
i'm honored to participate in today's
event
as liz mentioned the title of my
presentation is the innovative
approaches to discovery but through
biomarker discovery in the direct
development process and today i will
speak to you about the use of geomics
spatial biology platform to innovate
biomarker discovery and development
not a string business is focused on
building tools for biomarker discovery
and translational research the company
was founded in 2003 from technology out
of the institute of systems biology
and it is headquartered in seattle
washington the company has over 700
employees globally and have deep
expertise in the life sciences tool and
are leaders in the spatial biology
technology space
our two main instrument products are
displayed in this slide
and our technologies have been featured
in over 4 000 peer-reviewed publications
and although our primary focus is not
his
is not diagnostics we do have a history
in
developing
diagnostic products as is featured by
the prosignia for breast cancer
today i will provide you with a brief
introduction to biomarkers and why these
are so critical in the drug development
space
i will discuss some of the current
biomarker strategies and challenges in
doing this type of work
then
i will review a number of case studies
to demonstrate how our genomics platform
has already created significant impact
and has revolutionized biomarker
discovery across all facets in the drug
development process
so why are biomarkers so important in
the drug development process
biomarkers serve as a point of reference
in measuring biological processes
they represent healthy and disease
states and this can be used to measure
response
to exposure or response to therapeutic
intervention
biomarkers are already part of
everyday's clinical practice i'm sure
that when you've gone to the doctor's
office they likely measure your blood
pressure
measure your weight
perhaps taken your temperature and
weight
and so it possibly runs in blood tests
all these are examples of biomarkers
that are assessed
to evaluate your health and some of them
are also monitored for certain diseases
in drug development biomarkers are
essential and have a great potential to
deliver on the precision medicine
promise and it does so by identifying
patients that will benefit from
therapeutic intervention and so this is
these are very critical because they can
improve the success rate in drug
development and have the potential to
demonstrate efficacy faster than
conventional approaches
given all these points
nanostrengths proven spatial biology
technology offers high
opportunities for biomarker discovery
it enables hyplex protein and whole
transcriptome scale profiling of
distinct distinct regions of tissue
microenvironments using very small
amounts of sample
and it also
affords you the robust reproducible
usable data that has already been that
has already accelerated scientific
discoveries as evidenced by the number
of published research studies using our
technology
scientists in biopharma are constantly
formulating a biomarker strategy with
their cross-functional teams
no matter where they see it in the r d
organization whether in discovery
pre-clinical translational or clinical
space they will be defining a biomarker
strategy to meet regulatory demands for
a drug
and they might also be defining an
exploratory biomarker strategy that will
provide them with the most biological
insight
this discovery or exploratory activities
in the biomarker studies opens the door
for creative and innovative approaches
not a string geomix technology fits well
in this context
there are a number of biomarker
categories
and of the biomarkers being explored
where they're used to meet a regulatory
milestone
or as part of an exploratory strategy
they fit into one or more of the
biomarker categories that are listed on
the right side of this slide
the specific approaches to biomarker
discovery is dependent on the drug
development state and the specific
insight needed to be gained
under each of these steps in the direct
development continuum
that are listed in the screen arrows i
have listed a specific insight that is
generally sought
the type of biological sources for these
studies and biological assays will vary
depending on the stage of the
development
because of the different uh
sources of samples and the types of
assays that are being used
this can present significant challenges
for instance biomarkers discover in the
early stages of drug development are
often derived from experimental models
this means that the results from these
studies must be sufficiently robust to
ensure they validate and are impactful
in the later stages of development
biological methods can also be
a concern in especially in the early
stages of drug development where there
not be something where they may not be
so robust
analytical verification of methods can
help improve this process
another challenge comes from clinical
samples
there is a lack in standardization in
the collection processing and storage of
these samples are often limiting
and this hinders the execution of
biomarker plans
if not managed well these challenges can
significantly slow down the biomarker
development progress
in this presentation i would only focus
on spatial biology approaches to
biomarker discovery in this
in this presentation
in this application we focus on
profiling rna and protein in tissues
special biology is more than a buzzword
with special transcriptomics having been
declared
the method of the year in 2020 and
special biology as one of the
technologies to watch in 2022
there is no doubt that the special
biology is a new frontier in molecular
biology
special biology uses in-situ-based
approaches to study the cellular
composition and function within the
tissue's own two or three dimensional
context
especially especially biology technology
helps to map the spatial architecture of
a cell and how it interacts with it with
its environment geomics does this
through specially profiling
rna and protein expression
in simpler terms in special biology
studies we're trying to understand how
tissues are put together how they are
organized
we adapted the concepts and images by dr
aviv vrajev from the broad institute to
represent what special biology offers
in bulk genomics we take chunks of
tissue
mix everything together to make a
homogeneous solution and then generate
data from this
signals from this represented cells can
be
easily disappeared
as technology has evolved
to using single cell approaches we
learned how much information we have
been missing
we can resolve cells clusters
but we still don't know how these cells
were organized and how they interact as
a unit
more recently using high plex spatial
biology tools such as yomik csp
we are now able to put all this
information in context
we can see a positional map of cells and
by profiling their protein and gene
expression we should be able to better
understand not only how these cells are
put together but also understand how
they interact with each other and for me
this is very exciting
the special characterization of
biomarker modalities has been shown to
be more effective
data published in this study
demonstrated that high plex spatial data
are better more or more effective
approaches for predicting response to
checkpoint blockade
here we're showing a rock plot
and is showing that the
multiplexing of
immunohistochemistry
is superior
relative to the other biomarkers
and those were included singleplex
immunohistochemistry
cmb and gene signatures
another study published by mark
comparing an 18 gene signature measuring
tumor inflammation spdl1
showed superior performance in
predicting response to pd-1 blockade
in head and neck tumors
this 18 gene signature was called [ __ ] by
mark and has become to be known by many
as as a tumor inflammation signature or
test
the same test assay which by the way was
developed by nanostring in collaboration
with work
show that this the t-score predicted
clinical benefit
merck generated bulk gene expression
from ffp samples from patients
participating in the clinical study
they used another string encounter
platform and came up with an 18 gene
signature or jet biomarker that was used
as predictor of response to bd1 blockade
results from the study are depicted in
the scatter plot
in the x axis
you can see that this goes t scores
represented
and the y axis represents
progression-free survival measured in
days
the red dots represent patients that met
complete clinical response or partial
response
and you can see most of the red dots
fall on the right side of or area of the
plaque with higher tissue values
this means that most tumors that showed
benefit from the treatment have high
tumor inflammation
the blue dots represent patients with
stable disease that did not meet
clinical response but have high test
values
by focusing on the black dots along the
x-axis
you can appreciate that not all inflamed
tumors respond to therapy
and and that non-inflamed tumors rarely
respond
so based on the results from the merck
study we know
identification of inflamed tumors is
necessary but not sufficient for
predicting response to immunotherapy
we now understand that there are
different tumor immune phenotypes
the images on the left side depicts an
immune excluder tumor and the image on
the right side depicts a highly inflamed
tumor
based on both gene expression profiling
used to generate tumor inflammation
signature scores depicted in the in the
circles with values
it this shows above tumors deal high
test scores
the localization of immune cells depicts
different tumor biology as you can
appreciate in the enclosed circles
and this suggests that bulk or single
cell analysis cannot accurately profile
tissue biology and the spatial context
is important
given the cellular heterogeneity in
tissue samples
and the ever-expanding combination of
therapeutic strategies there is a
critical need to gain the most
biological information possible from
limiting amongst of clinical samples
with the growing focus and appreciated
value of special information
and the limitations with current spatial
technologies
researchers are used to trade off high
plex assays for loop-like spatial assays
hyperexpression profiling
such as rna-seq provides a lot more
benefit in high context of plexi level
quantitative readout and precision
compared to compared to
low plex imaging such as
immunohistochemistry assays
and these are often
uh
they offer special benefit but often
they do not
offer the quantitation the plexi level
or the precision benefit that high plex
assets do
so this leaves researchers to generate a
lot of data with no spatial context
in order to generate both high flex and
look like spatial data from their
samples scientists must consume
significant amounts of tissue samples
and often risk not able to not being
able to generate any data using standard
approaches
understanding the limitations that
clinical researchers scientists are
faced with
and that their goal is to get as much
information from their research samples
as possible
spatial biology tools offer a great
solution
geomic csp enables scientists to
generate as much information as they
want using hyplex spatial rna and
protein assays
this approach
offers interrogation of over 100 protein
markers and up to 18 000 rna targets
using very small amounts of sample
and by the way very soon we will have
we will make available a new workflow
that will enable the measurement of both
protein and rna on the same tissue
section so stay tuned for more new
sundays
there has been some debate as to the
level of resolution special biology
technology should have
in my opinion
spatial biology requires tools
at three distinct spatial scales
for multi-cellular analysis geomics is
the ideal platform you can use a variety
of morphology guided roi selection
strategies to profile relevant biology
of cells in an area as small as a
hundred micron
for single cell or subcellular scale the
special molecular imager is a perfect
solution offering resolution as low as
10 micron to profile single cells and as
long as one micron to profile
sub-cellular structures
the special molecular images is a new
platform and will become commercially
available later this year
together these two technologies
platforms can help accelerate your
research in biomarker discovery
you can use geomics as a discovery tool
to generate robust datasets from your
tissues
or interest of your tissues of interest
and enable new discoveries
you can sample as many or as few regions
or areas of interest as required by your
experimental plan
you can use scalable and customizable
panels to ensure protein or rna express
to
to
to measure protein or rna expression
and you can compare and contrast
cellular composition in different tissue
compartments
and generate hypotheses as to their
function and interactions
if your research needs
require single resolution the spatial
molecular images enables your success
enabling rna and protein profiling at
single cell and subcellular resolution
for up to a thousand targets for
a thousand genes
so how do we generate all these robust
spatial data
first samples undergo staining using uv
photoclipable oligos and fluorescent
antibodies for the protein assay
or they
undergo staining with uv photo cleavable
oligos in rna scope probes for the rna
assay
after staining the slide is image
and the image is analyzed using the
system's computer interface and software
this selects regions or areas of
interest according to the experiment to
your experimental plan
once regions of interest are selected
the automated process in the system will
take over to eliminate and uv cleave
oligos one roi at a time
immediately after being cleaved all the
girls are collected and dispensed into a
96 well microtiter plate
after processing all regions of interest
the samples are processed to be read out
on an encounter instrument
or for sequencing on an illumina
sequencer
data collected from each roi can then be
analyzed and
visualized following this workflow one
can reveal morphology for biological or
biological compartment specific
expression profiles
in this example a masking strategy was
applied to profile a total of 10 areas
of interest
areas 1 through 5 collected areas of the
tumor in association with invasive
martyr margin
area 6 through 9 collected areas of the
tumor center and area 10 was collected
to represent normal non-neoplastic
tissue
because of the masking strategy use the
total number of data points derived from
this experiment is 20.
each area yields two data points
allowing you to compare and contrast two
different morphologies with two
different individual
tissue compartments
there are a number of roi selection
strategies that can be used depending on
your scientific question
you can follow a geometric or you can
select a geometric strategy
to use for
defining the heterogeneity of expression
in different regions of a tissue
you could also use segmentation which i
just discussed
to evaluate the expression profile of
distinct biological compartments
there's also a cell type specific
contour ingredient graded options that
are available to you for use depending
on the best approach to address the
scientific questions that you need to
address
our geomix protein panels offer great
flexibility in the biology and number of
targets you can interrogate
you can measure over 140 protein targets
that are relevant in cancer and
immunology research studies
the content is partitioned into
functional modules so that you can pick
and choose what is relevant for your
experiment
there are also over 100 protein targets
that are relevant in neuroscience
research and the content is also
partitioned into functional modules
we have partnered with appcam and and
this gives you access to over 6000
antibodies that you can include in your
essay as custom content
i want to highlight that there is a
workflow that is depicted at the bottom
of this slide
we have defined best practices that uses
the users can follow in order to ensure
high quality results from customer
customized content using use in their
research studies
in terms of rna content there are three
panels
that are available
and
two out of the three panels are read out
on illumina sequencers
the whole transcriptome panel is
available for both human and mouse and
target over 18 000 genes the internal
verification experiments have shown high
sensitivity and specificity for this
assay
the assay is highly robust as we can see
on this chart you can easily detect over
6 000 genes in roi's sizes of as small
as a hundred micron
the cancer transcription atlas is
another panel that surveys over 1800
genes across more than a hundred
pathways and then the rna immune pathway
panel is our smallest panel consisting
of about 80 targets and ripped out in
the encounter system
all panels are customizable you can add
anywhere from 10
to
up to 30 targets of interest
so
the geomex platform can take your
precious clinical samples
build expression profiles for segments
and extract interesting information
but a modern platform needs to be more
than this
our approach has been to have an open
design that encourages interrogation of
metadata with spatial information
this allows users to input various
pieces of information into the analysis
workflow
gene expression signatures can be
incorporated for instance
images from other platforms can be used
to inform regions of interest selection
this is a nice feature to have you can
use
your existing immuno immunofluorescence
reagents to obtain images that can be
superimposed
on serial sections to select your
regions of interest
this can be very powerful and get
studies started much faster
you can also include clinical
annotations for example
to streamline your data analysis process
the geometry subforce includes a data
analysis pipeline that can be used to
generate and visualize results as well
as to generate publication ready
graphics
data files are interoperable allowing
users to
also use
whatever informatics tools they have
access to
our platform has been supported
or has supported many research studies
as as early as of this month we've
reached our 100th published publication
milestone
and this keeps growing
there is no better attestation to the
performance and quality of data for any
technology platform
than the number of high impact research
paper
they can derive in a short timeline and
we're very proud of this fact
there are multiple research
fields taking advantage of our spatial
technology
the oncology and infectious disease
research field have contributed the
largest proportion of publications as
you can see in this pie chart
you can also see the that many disease
areas that have been studied by each of
these research fields in the in in these
publications
this is a great attestation that our
technology can generate high value
across many tissue types and disease
areas
and to be clear the content analysis
presented here is based on research
papers only and does not include
supporting publications such as reviews
and other types of publications
so where in the drug development process
can special biology make the most impact
because the technology requires
a very specific sample type solid tissue
or tissue microarrays our special
biology technology could impact
just across yeah just just about
anywhere across the entire drug
discovery process
to name a few applications
in the discovery process in the
discovery and pre-clinical research
stage geomics can be used to target for
target discovery
characterization of disease models and
mechanisms of action
or understand the mechanism of action
in translational research
the technology can be used to help
generate datasets for deep
characterization and profiles of
clinical samples that may not be
associated with a clinical trial
but are used to derive insight about
disease and drug mechanism of action
in the clinical development stage
the best application besides the usual
pharmacodynamic studies could be reverse
transactional studies
going back to analyze samples for which
there are clinical metadata
including outcome data
and this can be used to explore
predictive biomarkers for patient
selection and start to generate
hypotheses for alternative therapies
according to response status
the case studies that i will review next
demonstrate how geomics can predict
clinical efficacy faster and how this in
turn can help accelerate the drug
discovery process
well i've selected a total in a few
samples and i will give you a very high
level overview
to demonstrate application in
pre-clinical studies translation
research and
activities in reverse translation
these are two examples representative of
the type of studies that geomics could
enable
in the discovery and pre-clinical
research areas
first on the left panel
this is a study conducted by a group at
the jackson labs geomics whole
transcriptome and protein assays
were used to characterize a specific
alzheimer's mouse model
azure aware characterization of
experimental models is a requirement to
ensure one can trust the data generated
from research studies conducted in these
models
here using the mouse whole transcripta
message investigators were able to
confirm upregulation of
disease-associated microglial genes in
the expected tissue morphologies
in this knockout
in this knock-in model
then on the right panel
this is a study conducted by a group at
the vanderbilt university
geomics was used to study
sting agonist response in the b16
melanoma mouse metal and they identify
s100 a9 and b7h3 as possible immune
escape mechanisms i'm not showing that
data
by evaluating protein expression in
different morphological compartments in
the tumor from these models and
associating values to survival this
group was able to demonstrate improved
survival using sting agonist alone
compared to the controls and even better
survival in the animals treated with a
combo approach including the sting
agonist and immune checkpoint blockade
so these two are good examples of
example of of
of studies that you would carry out in
this a particular click discovery and
pre-clinical space
this next
study
is another example that was conducted by
the ih3 biomedicine group
this is a good example of how geomics
can be used to characterize specific
components of the tissue
microenvironment
and to elucidate key molecular
characteristics of disease
this group set out to investigate the
immune contextual of tumor and stroma in
pbr gamma-high muscle-invasive bladder
cancer samples they were able to confirm
the expected t cell exclusion phenotype
in ppr gamma high that you can see in
the first image on the left hand side
and they were also able to confirm the
infiltrator tumor phenotype that is
expected to to occur in ppr gamma low to
more subtypes and that's that image on
the right side
that can a as skin as you can see in the
image represented here
the tumor subtypes are associated with
the test values that are also
represented in the
upper
corners for each of the images in the
circles
and the protein expression data for cd3
for each subgroup and tissue compartment
was also as expected as you can see in
the bar chart on the right hand side
to better understand the immune
exclusion phenotype this group tested
the tumor aois of ppr gamma high and ppr
gamma low patients to see whether there
were other markers differentially
expressed in these samples
at the protein level on the left side
geomic csp distinctly shows differential
expression of immune cell markers for
the different bladder tumor subtypes
as you can see on the left side of the
heat map
the expression of immune markers are
less abundant as depicted by the blue
color
in roi is collected from the tumor
regions of ppr gamma height samples in
that sense to be expected
on the right hand side of the heat map
the rois from tumor regions of ppr gamma
low have higher expression of immune
related markers
also as expected and that's repeated by
the red color
we can also appreciate a cluster in the
middle of the heat map with rois that
show varying degrees of expression for
different immune cell markers so this is
an interesting finding
the volcano plot on the right is showing
results from the same areas of interest
in the two tumor subtexts
reproducing the same immune
representation in ppr gamma low and
confirming the expected rna expression
values for the ppr gamma high tumor
subtype
as already highlighted in clinical
studies each tissue section uses
critic
each tissue section used
is critical to the overall study design
because the physical samples are usually
very small
as such prioritizing experiments often
leaves key questions of biomarker
studies to go unanswered and so the
second objective for this study was to
determine if geomix was a viable option
for studies that had limiting sample
amounts in bladder cancer molecular
subtyping is known to impact patient
outcomes
and so therefore this was important for
this group to establish
they took advantage of the flexibility
of the assay and customized the contents
to include several genes in the rna
expression panel that was used to test
the capacity of genomics dsp to capture
this biology
using a single slide for tumor samples
that had been previously subtyped using
rna sequencing
geomets was able to accurately subtype
luminal and basal muscle muscle invasive
bladder cancer samples
the heat up on the right is showing the
results of unsupervised
hierarchical clustering of roi's profile
using custom using a custom gene set
that was spiked into the standard rna
panel
besides the suitability for discovery
and development of biomarkers for
patient selection this study
demonstrates the robustness and
reliability of the data generated by the
geomex platform
and this was using very small sample
amounts this study also suggests that
results generated using geometrics could
likely be translatable for
developing essays in standard platforms
another important category of biomarkers
is drug development in drug development
is predictive biomarkers and this study
published by david reim's lab at the
yale
university demonstrates the advantage of
the geomix platform and the unique
opportunity this type of represents this
this type of represent retrospective
analysis represents in drug
development this study used tissue
microarrays from baseline biopsies to
determine if digital spatial profiling
could reveal
novel predictive biomarkers either
singularly or in combination across
multiple biological compartments of the
tumor
and its immune micro environment
they use a masking strategy to enrich
four tumor cells or cd60i cd68 cells in
the in the areas of interest and that's
depicted in the right hand side of this
slide
they profiled the expression of 44
proteins in more in morphological
context across 59 patients that
underwear that underwent immune
checkpoint inhibition therapy
analyzing results for association with
patient outcome they found several
probes
primarily in the stromal compartment
were associated with patient outcome
these are listed on the table in the
upper right
quadrant of this slide
video 1 shows strongest association with
overall survival in the cd68 compartment
and b2m in the cd45 compartment was
associated
with both progression-free survival and
overall survival
with strongest association with pfs in
cd45 compartment
this study demonstrates that the value
of comp of the of compartment masking to
reveal mechanistic
mechanistically rational associations
with clinical outcomes
so it once again proves the value of the
spatial resolution of these biomarkers
if bulk analysis had been run these
associations may have been missed due to
the fact that the majority of tissue
on on most slides was tumor
and the meaningful associations were in
non-tumor regions
importantly this study further
highlights how geomics can enable
meaningful investigations with limited
patient samples
in conclusion i hope that i have
convinced you that non-string spatial
biology technology geomic csv
offers reliable and innovative biomarker
discovery solutions these are applicable
at every step of the drug development
continuum
in basic and early discovery or in in
basic and early development studies
through the use of high plex protein and
rna options available for human and
mouse you can find new discoveries
in translational research studies you
can generate deep characterization of
clinical samples
and in clinical studies beyond the
standard biomarker analysis
reverse translational activities are low
hanging fruit
all of this can benefit from hypox
customizable scalable content
highly reproducible data
translatable results and by this i mean
uh results that could easily be
translated to clinical facing assays or
technologies
you can get the most biological insight
from clinical samples using very small
amounts of sample
and it maximizes
you maximize your success and increase
speed in drug development to impact
patients lives
with that i thank you for your attention
and i'm happy to answer any questions
uh thank you so much dr angliano for
joining us today and for sharing your
insights into both biomarker discovery
as well as spatial biology
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
all right let's get started first
question for you
what types of studies would benefit most
from spatial profiling
the type of studies that would benefit
more from spatial profiling
are those
where a lot of research has already been
conducted for instance and you have
identified
specific biomarkers that haven't been
very successful in
proving to have clinical utility i think
the example that we gave here today with
pdo1
it's a good example
so by including
the spatial context in the research this
group was able to
bring value to pdl1 in the context with
spatial context to elucidate a predicted
value
great second question for you here
when would you recommend looking at each
type of analyte are there areas where
rna or protein would prove most
insightful
i think is it each
target offers different type of
information and in combination you
probably get a much better picture rna
profiling it's it is it gives you
highest um content so you have higher
much more information that you can
derive from a sample
and you can predict you can generate
hypotheses about
a specific pathways that that you could
potentially then test on for instance
the protein assay to to ensure that the
transcriptional expression is really
representative of the
translational aspect of
the functional process for the cells
with which is through the protein
expression
all right it looks like we have time for
one more question
final question for you
the ability to select roi seems like a
powerful tool that can enable scientists
to ask very precise and customized
questions in their research
can you share any insight into the
benefits of using geometric rois or
taking a segmentation approach for
example when designing your studies
sure so there are benefits to using a
geometric approach the best um
you know the best benefit would
be that you have to have better ability
to control the size
of the of the or or the composition of
the tissue within the roi section
so for instance you might find tissues
where the cell density might vary and so
by having the ability to use
uh a a
a geographical or geo a geographic
geometric i'm sorry roi
you have the ability again to control
the specific content that you're
collecting
while segmentation approaches are
valuable
those might inhibit your ability to
control for instance the representation
of the morphologies that you're
measuring in that space
but those are important things to keep
in mind especially how you're ultimately
going to
normalize and analyze your data
excellent and um with that i would like
to thank you again so much dr aguiano
for your time today and for sharing your
knowledge with us
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their extremely interesting questions
and i'd also like to thank our sponsor
nana string for sponsoring today's
webinar
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information that they
provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years so that will be until february
of
2024 and lab roots will alert you via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
and until next time goodbye